now a certain man was ill Lazarus of
Bethany the village of Mary and her
sister Martha Mary was the one who
anointed the Lord with the perfume and
wiped his feet with her hair her brother
Lazarus was ill so the sisters sent a
message to Jesus Lord he whom you love
is ill but when Jesus heard it he said
this illness does not lead to death
rather it is for God's glory so that the
Son of God may be glorified through it
accordingly though Jesus loved Martha
and her sister and Lazarus after having
heard that Lazarus was ill he stayed two
days longer in the place where he was
then after this he said to the disciples
let us go to Judea again the disciples
said to him rabbi the Jews were just now
trying to stone you and you are going to
go there again
jesus answered are there not twelve
hours of daylight those who walk around
during the day do not stumble because
they see the light of this world but
those who walk at night stumble because
the light is not in them after saying
this he told them our friend Lazarus has
fallen asleep but I am going there to
awaken him
the disciples said to him lord if he has
fallen asleep he will be alright Jesus
however had been speaking about his
death but they thought that he was
referring merely to sleep then Jesus
told them plainly Lazarus is dead
for your sake I'm glad I was not there
so that you may believe but let us go to
him Thomas who was called the twin said
to his fellow disciples let us also go
that we may die with him when Jesus
arrived he found that Lazarus had
already been in the tomb four days now
Bethany was near Jerusalem some two
miles away and many of the Jews had come
to Martha and to Mary to console them
about their brother when Martha heard
that Jesus was coming she went and met
him while Mary stayed at home Martha
said to Jesus Lord if you had been here
my brother would not have died but even
now I know that God will give you
whatever you ask of him jesus said to
her your brother will rise again Martha
said to him I know that he will rise
again in the resurrection on the last
day jesus said to her I am the
resurrection and the life those who
believe in me even though they die will
live and everyone who lives and believes
in Me will never die do you believe this
she said to him yes Lord I believe that
you are the Messiah the Son of God the
one coming into the world when she had
said this she went back and called her
sister Mary and told her privately the
teacher is here and is calling for you
and when she heard it she got up quickly
and went to him
now Jesus had not yet come to the
village but was still at the place where
Martha had met him the Jews who were
with her in the house consoling her saw
Mary get up and quickly go out they
followed her because they thought she
was going to the tomb to weep there when
Mary came where Jesus was and saw him
she knelt at his feet and said to him
Lord if you had been here my brother
would not have died when Jesus saw her
weeping and the Jews who came with her
also weeping he was greatly disturbed in
spirit and deeply moved he said where
have you laid him they said to him Lord
come and see Jesus began to weep so the
Jews said see how he loved him but some
of them said could not he who opened the
eyes of the blind man have kept this man
from dying then Jesus again greatly
disturbed came to the tomb it was a cave
and a stone was lying against it jesus
said take away the stone Martha the
sister of the dead man said to him Lord
already there is a stench because he has
been dead for days jesus said to her did
I not tell you that if you believed you
would see the glory of God so they took
away the stone and Jesus looked upward
and said father I thank you for having
heard me I knew that you would always
hear me but I have said this for the
sake of the crowd standing here
so that they might believe that you sent
me when he had said this he cried with a
loud voice Lazarus come out the dead man
came out his hands and feet bound with
strips of cloth in his face wrapped in a
cloth jesus said to them unbind him and
let him go
this is one of those stories where the
Gospel of John reminds us of the other
gospel tradition especially the figures
of Mary and Martha Lazarus is new we
don't have him in the Synoptics but he
plays a major role in this story and
what happens to Jesus afterwards and and
maybe implicitly in the gospel help me
think a little bit about Mary Martha
Lazarus why there why are they the
characters in this story yeah we
encounter Martha and Mary in the Gospel
of Luke and I think everybody knows that
story where Jesus comes to their home
and one of the gals is out busy getting
lunch together and the other was sitting
there by by the feet of Jesus and she
has chosen the better part and that is
Mary was chosen the better part that is
to be there at the feet of Jesus now mmm
we could go into whether that's a good
judgment all right but that's the way
the story goes
try preaching that to a bunch of
Protestant women that's right so there's
a kind of polarity between Martha and
Mary embedded in the tradition and I
wonder if John plays on that a little
bit I'll get back to that good snack but
then there's Lazarus and Lazarus who is
well and duly dead here clearly Laurie
yeah they the story goes that Jesus he
is told when he comes to deal with
Lazarus that he has been in the tomb for
four days and he stinks yeah that's
major underlining of the reality of
death I think that's right so he's well
and duly dead and so this is not a
miracle that can be misunderstood as a
healing exactly and I think that one of
the things that John is interacting with
is some of those other stories of
resurrections that we have in the
synoptic accounts the Daughter of Jairus
no or the son of the widow of Nan so
there's a there's a series of
resurrection stories and they tend to be
modeled on stories about the prophets on
Elijah and Elijah
and what they did in resurrecting people
from the dead or from near-death yeah
and in each of those other cases the
a dead person could be construed as not
really dead little ambiguity in a coma
this recent right so I think John wants
to insist here that Lazarus is indeed
dead and then he has the story of Martha
Mary oh by the way that there may be a
precedent for Lazarus in the figure of
Eliezer
in Luke who who they the beggar who is
Senate who was put in the bosom of
Abraham right right right right think
that's a foreshadow or another version
of this story well I don't know it got
to be a remote inspiration yeah in any
case we have Mary and Martha reacting to
Jesus who clearly has delayed his entry
onto this scene to be sure he comes in
when Lazarus yes indeed that you wonder
about the compassionate or dramatic
effect marvelous compassionless clear
right and you wonder what's going on in
in our evangelists so Martha comes onto
the scene and greets him in an effusive
way and seems to recognize him for the
important even divine or quasi divine
person that he is but does she really
get it right I think it's a fair
question does she really understand that
Jesus is in some sense that the key to
life and death I think she's in some
ways in the same position as Martha is
in in the Luke and account it is in a
position that somehow called into
question by the rest of the narrow and
then Mary when she comes on to they the
scene which he's told that Jesus is
coming she rushes out to greet him so
she's doing something similar to the
Mary in the earliest story she's there
at his feet she throws herself at the
feet of Jesus she worships him perfect
she shows by her bodily action what she
believes about him so it's not simply a
matter of verbal confession it's a
matter of concrete action I think that
that contrast is probably meant to be
taken into account but Jesus says more
or less the same thing to both he does
and here's where there's
an interesting theological play going on
the insistence in in this that I am
right in there here right now right here
the reservoir and the life and I'll
raise them up on the last day but
resurrection is something you experience
in the encounter with Jesus I think
Jonas is really strong on that point and
then trying to figure out what he means
by that and how the two affirmations
resurrection on the last day and
resurrection in the here and now hang
together
is one of the theological challenges I
don't know how is he huge theological
tile challenge I mean it seems to me
that this he he does that egg ome we've
talked about before only what he is now
his resurrection and the life but as I
read that the present tense of the I M
is very important I know that my brother
will rise again in the judgment at the
last day and Jesus response is right
here right now I am resurrection and
life so that whatever else whatever else
eternal life means for him it takes us
way back to John 3:16 they may have
eternal life
eternal life is not just life beyond the
grave though I think it is that in John
but it has something to do with with the
power of the eternal on the life that we
now live now how we play that I'd love
to hear you on that how do we play that
against the assurances that in my
father's house are many rooms I'm going
to prepare a place for you that doesn't
drop out entirely no but it gets highly
qualified by this strong sense on the
presence of resurrection yeah let me
come back to that text in John 14 about
in my father's house there are many
mansions and to think I think it ties in
very nicely to what I see John doing
with his Christian tradition here if you
you go back a little bit and think about
the controversies about resurrection
among early Christians because most
early Christians believed in some way or
rather that Jesus was resurrected from
the dead
absolutely when I say most of just
holding out the possibly there's
somebody on the list yeah
but they they differ it I think on how
they understood that and we can
certainly see that difference bubbling
to the service in Paul's dialogue with
his Corinthian congregation in 1st
Corinthians 13
where he he wants to insist on the
reality the objective reality of the
resurrected Christ but he also wants to
not in the
the rational beliefs of these these folk
and say flesh and blood yeah this is not
this is not just gonna be it's not you
Ani walking it's not Bartlett returned
there's a transformation that's going to
take place so I think John in his own
way is wrestling now you do and I think
John is also in some ways tying into the
language of early Christians that again
we meet in Paul in Romans where
referring to the baptism rich was it in
Baptism we have died and we have died
with Christ and therefore let us walk in
the newness of life
Paul nuancing it but there's a death and
resurrection now area now in Baptism the
I'm sure when you see that in Colossians
turn with a little less nuance we have
died with Christ and we have raised with
so Christians can talk in resurrection
terms about their rebirth experience to
get the help of the Nicodemus Odin so I
think there's a tie-in here between John
11 and John 3 and rebirth and
resurrection both free refer to the same
event in the life of the believer coming
to life in the here and now
that gets us then and to that Last
Supper discourse and the many mansions
yeah I've I've come to understand that
text is in some ways
John's equivalent to first Thessalonians
4 the so called rapidly next because
what Jesus says in John 14 is that I'm
going away and coming back and I will
take you with me yeah so doesn't use the
language language of rapture but uses
the language of gathering up which is I
think related now I don't want to go
into rapture stuff but I think there's a
God because we can't really wait deep
indeed but what I do want to point to is
what what happens after that in John 14
okay where Jesus talks about coming in
being with his disciples he and the
Father together and so his coming back
and taking them to himself is not an
eschatological event it's an element of
relationship that he comes to dwell in
them in the here and now with his father
so again relating it to Paul and
thinking about how Paul could say I live
now not i but Christ and me John says
equivalently you live now not you but
our Father and father died on you you
yeah and when you live in that
relationship you live the resurrected
life have been reborn yeah now this is
still at the level of symbol and image
and metaphor and I think it has yet to
be cashed out but I think that's where
John is going with it taking these these
eschatological categories not denying
that there may be some sort of future
reality that we cannot fully envision in
our limited physical sensibility but
nonetheless saying whatever that reality
is it's grounded in and it's continuous
with the reality that you experience
here no I think that's very strong by
the time you get to first John which I
think comes out of the same community I
don't know about whether you do or not
but at least the same kind of stream
there is a that remains but there's a
sense we don't yet know what we will be
there is this the future eschatology
comes back in but I do think for
whatever reason John's emphasis is over
I don't think he denies that future
moment but over against it now as
judgment now is life right now is
resurrection yeah this is one of those
themes where we have alluded to this on
a number of occasions people have seen
levels in the gospel someone coming in
trying to correct yeah yeah yeah get the
orthodoxy back in right but if someone
were correcting things why not get out
the objectionable stuff no I think it's
intentionally there yeah and I think
it's part of a coherent theological
statement that John is trying to make
well we come up with our categories and
we say you realized eschatology and
future eschatology or where your Free
Willy or predestination but John didn't
know he had to worry about our
categories that's right you had a story
to tell
speaking of which Lazarus is is beloved
in this story and there's this Beloved
Disciple who somehow witness for all the
scenes of the gospel or at least many of
them is is Lazarus the hidden Beloved
Disciple there are some people who think
so no and we had a pause for just a
minute on the Beloved Disciple he and he
appears with that phrase that is the one
whom Jesus loved or the disciple whom
Jesus loved explicitly at the Last
Supper right and at the Last Supper he
rests on the bosom of Jesus
as we'll see and then he appears that
they the foot of the cross and there's a
little tag there about he has the one
who has seen these things write to them
at his testimony is true that's probably
a reference to whoever this beloved
assignment is and then he's there at the
empty tomb were going to be out and get
him a little later and he's finally
there in John 20 water the fish fry or
the sea of Tiberias and so there were
four places where he appears and I'll be
darned if I can figure out any of those
four places who he is yeah me neither so
I just thought maybe you'd hit it no
hope you move on no but some people say
this is there's that love reverence yes
he loves you because I think this is
another very clever move on the part of
our evangelist there may well have been
someone out there who was a disciple of
Jesus and sort of stands at the source
of the tradition that Jesus that John
represents but I think the evangelists
when he came to write that the gospel in
this current form adds this character
he's not in in the synoptic gospel right
Ansem and adds him in a way that you
can't figure out who he is because you
know what's happened over the course of
the history of reading this text people
have gone back to it time and time again
trying to figure out absolutely and just
about any named disciple of Jesus and
they yeah but maybe if you keep going
back long enough to the fourth gospel
you'll finally find out who the real
witness is and who is the real witness
we all know the one and the only witness
Jesus Jesus yes yeah so I think it's a
device to hook you in and get you
encounter I just and I talked about one
course I taught on John one time iyt yes
I told him on the whole the right answer
to any question I ask you about John's
Gospel Jesus yeah who's the witness
Jesus who's the bread of life Jesus and
worked extremely well